now I'm not saying that women can't
disagree
lord knows Carol and I have had our
moments but I've never seen anything
quite like this Susan Collins a
Republican senator fixed it for the
controversial Brett Kavanaugh to become
a Supreme Court justice in the u.s. in
the face of credible evidence that he
distorted at least one girl at high
school yes ladies one year on from those
first allegations against Harvey
Weinstein the hash tag me to backlash is
in full swing Donald Trump's openly
working it to rally his base for next
month's elections his attack on
Cavanaugh's accuser professor Blasi Ford
has been dubbed the patriarchal riposte
to the movement that's been a global
rallying point for women's anger against
male privilege
I don't want men victimized for being
men apart from Nick that's but it
saddens me that so many women have
jumped on the me to backlash bandwagon
quite unnecessarily
we've got Donald Trump for that we don't
need women for Trump or women for
Cavanagh piling into I don't want to say
it but women beware women why can't the
sisterhood stand strong let me start by
saying I worry that me too is now being
used as a political tool to in some
cases intimidate men and to battle them
with the strength of the me to movement
is that it has exposed the experiences
of women who have been abused I think
the great weakness of it is that all a
woman has to do now is to say that she
has she's to accuse a man of assault and
she is believed now the thing that got
me about kristinb Lacey Ford when she
gave her testimony at the Senate
it looked wholly sincere to me but I
don't know if it's true but what
happened was or a lot of a lot of women
went on her
there were people protesting outside
saying you know believe her believe her
believer she there was not a scrap of
evidence to back up her claims there was
not there was nothing that could have
helped police bring a prosecution there
was nothing that could have got that
case to court and yet
watch what Christine place before did
she cried and her tears were her
evidence and America a lot of America
believed her now this this worries me
because any you mentioned Susan Collins
Susan Collins talked about she talked
about she said she was back in Kavanagh
because of due process
yeah cousins the law now the law says
you have to have evidence before you
touch it and it's not ringing her up
because we have a clip from Susan
Collins in which she says the the burden
of proof is there more likely than not
one which was a new one for me but let's
hear from her the facts presented do not
mean that President that Professor Ford
was not sexually assaulted that night or
at some other time but they do lead me
to conclude that the allegations failed
to me the more likely than not standard
therefore I do not believe that these
charges can fairly prevent judge
Kavanaugh from serving on the court the
problem listen this is a whole gray area
historic sexual abuse or crime is a real
gray area Melania Trump has also come in
on this side to say women who accuse men
of these things must provide evidence
now the problem is we all know that
there is very rarely evidence of
something like that and it supports a
that of course the judge governor has
refuted all those allegations ania so we
just need to get that on the record what
I don't understand is and let's just
stay with the judge there and let's just
stay with his so that it never happened
the tone of what you were saying seems
to imply that because of the importance
and it is important that women feel
empowered that if they have been
sexually abused or because of the
importance of that maybe a few good men
could get burned
No
No let's activate sir I'd like to like
to make something clear which is this
what I'm talking about
is the way that I feel women are
aligning themselves against the me to
movement because the me to movement
actually hasn't been terribly successful
it's still men who are in power and
women align themselves with power so
they are Newsies male in our case that
to innocence and shore up of their own
positions within the patriarchy that I'm
afraid of laughter you have to be mean
tonight one more thing on the me to I do
not want want men to go crash and burn
in flames innocent men I think all I
want the me to movement to achieve is if
men have done wrong to acknowledge it
apologize and everybody move on I don't
want to see them destroyed i I think
process is very important and I think
you know the danger in the meter
movement is as people become a hugely
respect like Margaret Atwood have said
this kind of lit mob justice approach
but having said that we know as Rachel
pointed out that it's very difficult for
women who have historically been the
victims of these kind of salts to prove
it evidence the process has not been on
their side and I think that this was
difficult because it wasn't a criminal
trial there was a process it was very
but then you have President Trump saying
that Kavanagh was proved innocent which
is completely wrong he wasn't proved
innocent it was just that she wasn't
able to prove guilt and I just want to
show you something from a woman we all
know who's not exactly what you see when
you close your eyes and think of the
sisterhood but let's hear her anyway I
don't know why also that we have to look
at every woman automatically as as a
victim if you're a woman every man is a
bad perpetrator when did this happen
that we line up according to political
lines or according to gender lines well
first of all Harvey Weinstein Carol you
said this has become very politicized
was a huge Democrat donor so the idea
that this is only going strategic after
Republicans or people on the right isn't
true and secondly an answer to Kelly and
Conway's point always women have always
always gone against the interests of
other women look at the suffragettes
that's one thing there soon as the
political hit because the the Democrats
had had lost the the white house that
lost the Senate and then they lost the
house and the yeah well a couple of
things in terms of whether or not dr.
Blasi Ford could provide evidence and
proof we'll never know because the FBI
investigation was faulted by the
Republicans there wasn't a thorough
investigation done so we'll never know
the other thing I just want to say is I
agree to a certain point with you Rachel
but I do think that what's happening
with the whole Cavanaugh issue is a real
backlash from women who are now deciding
that they're not having this anymore and
if you look at what happened 27 years
ago when the Republicans made the same
mistake with Clarence Thomas the year
after was the year of the women record
numbers of women ran for office and as a
result Bill Clinton won I mean though he
had his own issues and I think what's
gonna happen now what we're going to see
in the midterms is we will see a blue
wave but then following on for 2020 we
are gonna see record numbers of women
running for office to make sure that
actually there are more women in the
process deciding this stuff America very
angry at the way the Cavanaugh thing has
been correct about the majority or not
even evangelicals women are turning to
the Democrats in the data Carol it was
to remember the girls standing outside
at the Senate where she had a placard
and she said I'm protesting for my
twelve-year-old South a lot of these
women had yourself had really terrible
issues to have to face but none of that
was Cavanaugh's fault and yet he is
gonna suffer on the flip side you saw
conservative women coming out saying
even if these allegations are true I
don't care what what college boy hasn't
done that to a girl at a party with a
few drinks so Carol you know for
everyone but women
remember she was only attacked for
having a go with me to earlier this year
she says we are being told what is
proper to say and what we must stay
silent about and the women who refused
to fall into line are considered
traitors and accomplices as women we
don't recognize ourselves in this
feminism that beyond the denunciation of
abuses of power takes the face of a
hatred of men and sexuality and I think
that is I think that that's what it is
what's happened can we have a clip of
some of the women that you mentioned
Rachel's these are Trump women for Trump
I mean wow let's have a look I'm doing
just a few hours ago the US Senate
confirmed judge Brett Kavanaugh
number one I don't think they're as many
of them as we think there are because he
had to search hard to find her with her
with her plaque car engine is not what
it rubs women we will see in November
and I think we will see the Republicans
are going to learn the hard way for this
100